Now if we compare this to the vertex form that we just came up with, we can see
that we're already filling in things in most of the slots that we need. The left
hand side is good to go. We have our a set with this 3, and we almost have this
x minus h squared figured out. This isn't quite a perfect square yet though,
like x minus h squared is. So what do we need to add on to the expression x
squared plus 2x? Which we have inside these parenthesis, in order to have a
polynomial that we can factor to be in the form, x minus h squared, where h is
unconstant. Remember that if h is negative here, we end up with x plus some
constant. So don't worry if you're wondering how to get x minus a number here.
Just think about what we need to complete the square.